يعمل دماغنا دائمًا على معالجة
المعلومات من محيطنا
ومن داخله هو مركز القيادة المركزي لدينا ، حيث
يكون الدماغ هو أول مكان
يتلقى إشارة من هناك ينتقل
عبر الحبل الشوكي ويتفرع إلى
أعضائنا على سبيل المثال إذا لمست
سخونة  موقد الأعصاب في جلدك يرسل
رسالة ألم إلى دماغك والتي
تخبر عضلات يدك أن
تبتعد ، يمكنك أن تشكر نظامك العصبي
على رد الفعل السريع هذا ، فهو في
الأساس أسلاك أجسامنا تتكون من
ملايين الرسائل المجهرية التي
تسمى الخلايا العصبية  التي ترسل إشارات إلى
أجزاء من الجسم ولكن ما يحدث عندما
لا تعمل حواسيبنا الرئيسية بشكل صحيح
وذاكرة الكلام الحركية ويمكن أن يتأثر أكثر من ذلك بكثير
وفقًا للمعهد الوطني للصحة بالولايات المتحدة ،
فهناك أكثر من 600
مرض عصبي يصيب أكثر
من مليار شخص حول العالم  عالم
يتراوح من أمراض العضلات مثل
التصلب المتعدد إلى الأمراض المعرفية
مثل الزهايمر ويمكن أن يبدأ كل شيء
مع ضواحي صغيرة  م في الأسلاك لدينا
[موسيقى]